Sonic Youth which was a bit I love the
album Daydream Nation is a great album
and but I had this obsession with this
band called The Pixies now um I'm gonna
cry you're crying I'm gonna cry I
remembered there was a a mini mall in
Rancho Bernardo where I grew up this is
probably 89 90 in 1990 and I remember I
got cassette tapes of doolittle and
surfer rosa and also the EP I believe
and I remember listening to that those
albums just on repeat I just thought wow
man this is this music and this is
before like Nirvana right you know it's
like you know when a song starts real
silent and then you hit them I mean with
the [ __ ] you know you just you know
it goes with the [ __ ] music right and
so then cut tuned maybe you know I got
six months ago seven months ago I ran
into this dude right and I in my once I
saw this dude just you're not fill up
babe just let me say it right what I saw
this dude dark yesterday right it was
immediate like like holy [ __ ] yeah I
mean there he is
that's the guy I remember remember I
told you I moment I told I remember
exactly what you told me when you came
yeah how long ago was this six seven
months ago
oh yeah yeah and then but then when I
met him I pretended that I didn't know
who he was
classic Bobby classic it's called shadow
games right here shadow plays shadow
games okay and then but then as soon as
he mentioned that oh yeah you did you're
comedian right then I was just like Oh
buddy you're Joey the Pixies right so I
did at that whole foolish you know
social thing right but on
but him and I have become friends and
and I just immediately thought I got to
get him on Tiger belly but um I didn't
want to you know have him as a guest on
the via zoom so now that we have this
new space I invited him he said yes and
this is very exciting so we have give
him a round of applause for Joey
Santiago and he's the guitarist of one
of my favorite bands of all time The
Pixies hello Joey hello Joey
um you know you're gonna get a lot of
crap because you say though that you put
the article there but we do not care we
it was it's so stupid why we called
ourselves Pixies oh it's not the Pixies
are you even a fan Bobbi I say the
Pixies yeah what through with it I mean
ever since we did that that was our that
was a mistake
yeah Wow because bands at that time
weren't doing that the thing you know I
think that thou made fun of it I don't
bands that didn't have autumn anymore
yeah so who came up with the [ __ ]
title Pixies I did yeah
did you really yeah wait so let me get
this right okay because I didn't really
Wikipedia but let me make an assumption
okay they make me throw some stuff out